아무튼 그때 당시에 매입하고 1년
만에 매각을 했습니다
그리고이 건물이
2014년도에 무려
700억에 어
[음악]
네 안녕하세요 빌사남입니다 제가
오늘은
청담동 명품거리에 나와 있습니다
최근에 하이브가 SM 주식을 매입해
가지고 이제 1대 주주가 됐다 최대
주주가 됐다라고 이제 기사가 좀 많이
나가는데 그 sm엔터테인먼트의 창업자
저희 이수만 선생님의
빌딩 투자에 관해서 좀 설명을
드리고자 좀 현장에 나와 있는데
그래서 선생님의 빌딩 투자에서 저희가
그래도 봐야 될 교훈들이 좀 몇 개
있어요 일단은
명품거리에 있는이 건물이
99년도에 매입했습니다 그래서 저희가
그때 IMF
터지고 난 뒤거든요 그래서 얼마 되지
않아서 매입을 했는데 사실 그때
빌딩이 가격이 많이 떨어졌었고 그때
빌딩 산다 그러면 사람들이 이제 그
사지 마라
빌딩에 대한 부정적인 얘기가 굉장히
많았는데 선생님은 그때
99년도에 빌딩을 매입을 했습니다
그래서 명품 거리 지금 대로변 코너에
있는
빌딩이고 그래서 원래 연립주택 있던
건물을
매입을 해 가지고
지금 쓰고 있고요
실거래가가 2006년도 이후에 이제
나왔는데 그때 당시에 풍문에 의하면
한 20억원대
매입한 것으로 좀 알려져 있고
매입했을 때 대출은
약 15억 정도 받아서 이제 매입을
했습니다 지금 위치가 여기
갤러리아백화점 바로 옆에 있어서요
명품거리 초입에 있거든요 그래서
위치가 너무 좋고
명품 업체들이 좀 인근에 매입하기
시작했을 때였어요 여기 청담동
중에서도 가장 위치가 좀 좋은데
매입한 것으로 좀 보여지고요 뒤에
있는 건물까지도 같이 매입을 했거든요
그래서 그것도 이제 다가구
주택이었는데 두 개 동을
2005년도에
추가로 매입해서 다 같이 묶어서 지금
건물로 사용하고 있습니다 그래서
이렇게 대로변이나 이렇게 좀 도로가
넓은 곳에 부동산을 매입했을 때요
뒤에 빌딩을 같이 한번 작업해 보는
것도 괜찮거든요 그래서 지금 여기가
대로변이 평당 3억이 넘습니다
아무래도 뒤에 땅은 좀 저렴하게
받겠죠 그래서 같이
합침으로 인해서 또 다 같은 가격을
받을 수 있거든요 그래서 저는 이수만
선생님이 뒤에 것까지 같이 두 개
동을
작업을 해 가지고
매입한 거를 쓸 되게 좀 되게 높게
평가를 하고 그 99년도 이거
매입하고 난 뒤에 여기
염력 건물이 샤넬 건물도 사셨었어요
사셨다가 1년 만에 매각을 했습니다
근데 이때 샀을 때 대출을 한 40억
정도 받으셨더라구요 정확한 추정가는
알 수는 없지만 그냥 뭐 예상컨데 뭐
100억이 넘진 않았겠죠 그냥
예상치입니다 예상컨데 뭐 제 개인적인
예상은 한 5 60억 정도에 사지
않았을까 뭐 이렇게 예상이 되는데
아무튼 그때 당시에 매입하고 1년
만에 매각을 했습니다 그리고이 건물이
2014년도에 무려
700억에
샤넬의 매각이 됐습니다 그때 이제
선생님이
매각을 하지 않았더라면 하지
않았더라면
엄청난 시세차익을 얻을 수 있었는데
그때
매각 한게 좀 되게 아쉽게
느껴집니다 일단 여기서 느낄 수 있는
교훈은
IMF 터지고 얼마 안 돼서 이제
투자를 한 거죠 그때 당시에는 다
빌딩을 던질 때였는데 그때 이제 좀
공격적으로 매입을 했고 저렴하게
매입을 했고
뒤에 있는이 주택도 같이 매입을 한
다음에 다 같이 묶었습니다 그런
투자를 되게 좀 높게 평가하거든요
그리고 좀 한 가지 아쉬웠던 것은 저
샤넬 건물도 샀지만 좀 아쉽게 판 거
그냥 가지고 있었으면 어땠을까 그래서
여기서도 느낄 수 있는 교훈은 주요
지역에 있는 빌딩은 팔지 말아야 된다
위치가 좋은 데는 팔지 말라고 하는게
바로 이런 거거든요
샤넬이 그때 당시에 14년도에
700억에 사는데 지금은 더 비싸겠죠
그런 두 가지 교훈을 좀 얻을 수
있고 위기 사항이 오히려 좀 기회를
찾았고
뒤에 있던이 다가구주택 두 동을 아마
그때 당시에 좀 저렴하게 샀을 겁니다
정확하게 가격은 알 수는 없지만 뒤에
있는 두 동도 같이 매입해 가지고
전체적인 부동산 가치를 올렸고
끝까지 아쉬운 거는
샤넬 건물을 안 팔았으면 어땠을까
짐작하자면 지금 아마 한 1000억이
넘지 않을까 싶어요 저 샤넬 건물만
그리고 지금 청담동 명품거리 나와
있는 경우에 좀 말씀드리면 2 3년
전만 해도 상황이 많이 안 좋았어요
공실이 되게 많았는데 최근에는 진짜
공실이 거의 없습니다 거의 없고
웬만한 건물 꽉 차 있어요
원래는 저렇게 갤러리아라든지 이런
매장에 들어갔다가 사람들이 이런 좀
프라이빗한 곳에 좀 많이 오기 시작한
거 같아요 그런 부자분들이
명품 매장에 가면은
진짜 좀 프라이빗하게 쇼핑을 할 수
있습니다 그리고 건물도
정말 근사하게 많이 지어놨어요 정말
돈을 많이
들여서 되게 멋지게 건물을 신축을
했고 제가 좀 돌아다니면서 좀
특이하게 지은 건물들을 좀 몇 개
보여드릴게요
역시 사람이 없어요
되게 좀 프라이빗합니다 그래서
고객분들은 이렇게 걸어서 오진 않고
다 이제
차를 발레스
그리고 여기 이제 문 열어 주시는
분도 항상 있거든요 그래서 원래
이제요 건물을 샀던 거죠
요거를
2014년도에 샤넬이
매입을 했습니다 그래서 지금까지
가지고 있고 그래서 이런 그런 명품
업체에서 여기 또 직접 매입하기도
해요 그래서 요것도 아마 산 걸로
알고 있어요
여기 여기
딱 앞에 보여주시면
공실이 없습니다 저 건물 저기
앞에 하나 보이고 지금 이쪽으로는
공실이 없어요
와이프랑 같이 오면 안 되는
장소입니다
저기도 이제 신축 중에 있고 여기
보면은 아예 공실이 없어요
근데 불과 몇 년 전만 해도 공실이
진짜 많았다가 지금은 아예 없습니다
프라다도 이렇게
멋지게
큰 건물로 쓰고 있고
저기도 저는
약간이 건물 중에 좀 섬뜩한 건물을
저어갑니다 지금
[음악]
루이비통 건물 보면은 이쪽으로
저기 그 되게 유명한 분이시죠 저희
쿠사마 어르신이 저기 이제 조각상의
적이 있습니다 그래서 선생님 저기 그
파라다이스 시티 가면 또 호박
있잖아요 엄청 큰 거 그거 작품 하신
분이세요 지금 보면은 되게 예술적으로
지금 건물도 돼 있고 저기
풋사과 저기 어르신의 저렇게 큰
조각상이 저렇게 크게 있습니다
오늘도 있고
지금 저기 구찌 건물도
저기 내부가 진짜 굉장히 잘 되어
있어요 근데 제가 내부에 지금 좀
차량은 좀 어려워 가지고
저기랑 이제 디올 건물 저기도 저기
이제 벙어리 건물이 있고 그래서
딱 여기까진데 지금 보시면 알겠지만
1층에
빈대가 아까 거기 한군데 밖에
없었어요 저쪽에
거의 다 지금 다 차 있고 그냥
백화점 가서
작은데 들어가서 보는게 아니라 아예
이제 이쪽으로 와서 프라이빗하게 차
타고 와서
발레 맡기고이 매장에
딱 이렇게
단독으로 이용하는 그런
분들이 좀 많아진 것 같습니다
네 그래서
루이비통 건물 앞에서
굿사마 어르신 그 조각상에 있는
앞에서 마무리하겠습니다 그래서 오늘
영상 여기까지 하고요
다음 시간에 또 뵙도록 하겠습니다
감사합니다